hey guys welcome back to another video
and this is actually to be the second
upload of today I've never actually done
that for it's kind of weird to say that
but as I was going through Reddit and i
was going on through youtube i noticed
another youtuber a little bit of a hire
more subscribers than i am house phoenix
made a video like talking about this new
thing on reddit i guess someone by the
name of blaze via 725 was digging around
in some of the data folders and files
and found a few interesting things in
them regarding to future stuff that's
coming out so let's get started with
that so the first thing that he found
was a bunch of like pictures of the new
emblem outlines that are coming for each
of the factions one regarding to the
knights one to the samurai and one to
the vikings there's maybe like 12 or 13
more and then the next thing he started
finding was new UI icons for new game
modes and then more backgrounds more
like wallpaper material for ninjas and
Centurions if you want to see this I
will put the link in the description to
the whole thing if you want to checks
out yourself and what they look like but
then this is where it starts to come a
little bit interesting
he dug a little bit farther and he found
a few pictures of ranked modes that came
with images of what the ranking system
would look like and it's split up into
three game modes the first one is going
to be duel and brawl which is the duel
game mode which goes from bronze silver
gold platinum diamond all the way to
master the same thing for the objective
game modes which I would assume is
Dominion and then the last one is going
to be kill which is elimination in
skirmish now boss Phoenix was talking
about this and I completely 100% agree
with him on this how is this going to
work
ranked mode isn't yet set for this type
of behavior and such by the way the the
way that the game is and how unstable it
is it's not going to last the although
you yes you are kind of splitting this
player base a bit but that's not the
whole point though the connection issue
and then the amount of the characters
that are completing a complete different
skill gap
you could join a game and there's about
an 80% chance you're going to be joined
up with a guy who is using one of the
top five characters if it's not and then
if you don't worry about that then you
have to worry about protection you might
lag out of the game does that even if
there's a slight chance that you might
lag out of the game like on as a loss
and then how is this ranked going to
work I noticed that it split up into
three game modes so you could have like
a bronze rank in objective game mode or
Dominion it would be like mastering dual
so which is nice because not every
person wants to be one whole general
ranking but then how is it going to be
is it going to be like how it was a
couple updates ago where the kill
game-mode would be the same as
elimination in skirmish you queue before
elimination and skirmish and the kill
game-mode and then you you basically
throw the coin up and guess which game
would are going to be in you go to duel
and then say you queue up with a guy
buddy you go to brawl but if you go solo
you might get duel and brawl how is that
going to work where is this going to be
set another thing he found that I'd
really don't understand in my opinion is
the tournament lobbies it says another
thing I found which is quite interesting
is tournament lobbies I found out that
you get a loop based on the lobby
quality or progression and he says he's
not 100% sure I'll put the picture on
the screen but it looks like there's
like a tier list of the dilute that you
get from tournaments it's a whole weird
thing I don't really understand most of
it and not really no one else other than
that there really wasn't much left in
the data files that this guy had dug out
I can leave the link to it in the
description if you want to check out
some of the stuff for yourself as well I
do kind of like how they are you know
kind of planning for the future just in
case something does happen where you
know the player base skyrockets we get a
bunch of stuff they have stuff in the
back and ready just in case they're not
coming up with this stuff on the fly
anyway that's going to be the really the
end of the video just super quick I
didn't actually expect this to be a
thing I didn't know this is going on
this is tech an upload of the day it
kind of feels weird saying every time
don't normally do that anyway I will
probably
see you guys on Friday with the new
video of the dead stream or something
else comes up in the middle of the week
again anyway I'll see you all later guys
and peace out